give me your initial reactions to what
you saw here it's terrific speech I mean
those verbal stubbles won't matter much
what people will remember I think from
that speech is he's one of the most
talented communicators on our side to
Al's point the youth the new generation
the tomorrow candidacy is mostly upside
as you guys were talking about earlier
there is some risk that people make the
argument that he's the Republicans
Barack Obama and isn't that what God is
not a bad way right right right and that
got us into all these problems the lack
of experience but the truth is that'll
that'll care work itself out in the
primary if he performs in the primary
and he beats Jeb Bush and chris Christie
and Ted Cruz and Rand Paul some of these
very formidable political figures Scott
Walker he will come out of the primary
looking like he has tremendous gravitas
and I think is the best of both worlds
he has the tomorrow message that
youthful you know future-oriented
message combined with the guy who like
Barack Obama gained a lot in 2007-2008
by defeating Hillary Clinton he came
onto the stage in the fall of two
thousand eight looking like a tremendous
gravitas in part because he just been
through a brutal primary defeating a
formidable opponent I want to ask you a
bunch of other questions damn but I
first I've actually wanted to just get
marks my views on this I know you
haven't done your grades yet I don't
think you're still thinking those
through but just give me your [ __ ]
you're a quick overview on what you
thought you saw and heard tonight very
strong and right on the message you'd
want to be on my instinct is doing it
when he did it both right after Hillary
Clinton and at and at six thirty six
o'clock at night eastern time I'm not
sure he's going to get quite the
attention for what he's done as the two
senators who nets preceding it that's a
big part of what these announcements are
bad is to get attention raise money off
of them and introduce yourself the
country because insiders known but he's
still trying to introduce himself but it
varies obviously strong very well
written speech I thought maybe better
written than delivered even because it
did have some rough delivery I felt Isla
maybe a little nervous at the beginning
on maybe understandably so fundraising
more than one talented candidate in both
parties over the years as failed because
they couldn't raise enough money where
is he and winning over people in terms
of not grassroots fundraising which is a
question mark but super PAC fundraising
and bundling how is he doing there I
think it's finally I think there's a lot
of interest in them within a donut
community obviously Jeb has done
very well in the donor community early
but there is a sense you talked to
donors over and over and over there's a
real sense of there's been almost a
slowing down of people moving to
different candidates whether it's jabber
Walker they have lined up donors but
there is a sense there is no frontrunner
in this race and the polling shows that
the enthusiasm from the ground in the
early states from the from the activists
show that there is nobody dominating
this field so there is room and donors
are there for responding to that and you
just you hear donors talking about that
a lot donors are a little wigged out by
the fact that there's no frontrunner
donors you know abhor a vacuum in these
primary situations as to the press and
so I think a lot of donors are sitting
back and waiting I think Marco if he
performs well and generates a lot of
enthusiasm can get a lot of good it's
gonna be very frank we're fine without a
front-runner it's good story um this is
uh this is a cousin company excluded um
this is a guy who your friends with your
friends and the half a dozen of these
kids you haven't endorsed anybody I'm
wondering we talked earlier about
scrutiny I'm wondering if based on your
time with Marco Rubio and talking to
people around him are they prepared for
scrutiny are they worried about scrutiny
all I know is he was thoroughly vetted
when Romney was looking at him as a VP
running mate and I wasn't I was just as
John Edwards was thoroughly vetted when
Jerry looked at him as a running mate
sure but but the John Edwards issues
were many of them were following that a
period no look from from what I
understand i was involved with any of
the only to be clear the only comparison
i was making is it's a different type of
that once it once the entire national
press corps is breathing down your
throat trust me i know i i've seen that
with with other candidates i'm just
saying the only the only baseline we
have is that vetting is that's all I'm
saying is I understand it's a far
different environment when the whole
world is is climate chasing you but but
based on the vetting that Romney did
from what I understand there was nothing
in that vetting that is substantial
enough to give ever get anyone concerned
but look he's about to go through this
process it's it it's a healthy process
he's going to have his opponents Britain
you know going after him and dumping a
lot of our Pope he's gonna press
breathing down his throat so this is
this is all good trust me i'd rather be
in that situation him handed
to the fall than be in Hillary Clinton
situation what's his path to the
nomination where does he win right so
this is this is a challenge because as
other people have pointed out if you
look at the environment right now the
field right now there is no segment in
the electorate that he owns right if you
look at Ted Cruz you can see segments
sea legs back electret for whom he is
their first choice if you look even you
know for Jeb Bush there are segments of
the primary electorate more of the
establishment types but even some
conservative types that he owns there's
not a large segment of the electorate
that you would say that Marco owns that
on the one hand so so it's going to be a
very dynamic process and some people
have to rise and others are gonna be
have to fall in order for him to find
his space exhale want to go back to you
and ask you about this issue of Rubio
not having a voter base which stand
pointed out and and all of us and
looking at the polling have seen that if
he's to build a coalition not just in
Iowa and New Hampshire but nationally
where are the building blocks of the
Rubio coalition demographically well I
think a lot of us got to come from Jeb
Bush mark and then in addition he will
get more of the other tea party
conservatives movement conservatives I
don't think you'll do as well with
evangelicals at least as of now as as
Ted Cruz or as much as well with sort of
the young libertarian types as Rambo but
didn't get a slice of that but i think
if this guy really takes off it's going
to come out of jeb bush dan i want to
ask you i would listen looking at
listening to the speech looks listening
to it and looking at it on the screen
there was a place where where Rubio said
that before us now is the opportunity to
author the greatest chapter yet an
amazing story of America we can't do
that by going back to the leaders and
ideas of the past we must change this as
we were making by changing the people
who are making them he later talked
about how in many countries the highest
office in the land is reserved for the
rich and powerful and say that he was
not reading those words that i just read
those were obviously directed at Hillary
Clinton right fighting word but they
could also be easily directed at yet
bush it seems to me on some levels that
one of the one of the strengths of this
message the generational message and the
biographical message is that they
actually apply in both directions you
could hear a general election message
here how he
take on Hillary Clinton while also
taking shots effectively at the bush
frontrunner what I've been struck by
when I've spoken to him or spoken to
people who are working for him is his
message is is going to be the same
message in the primary as it will be in
the general it works in the primary as
much as it works in the general and they
say I once saw that was one of them
recently showed me his last ad his
closing campaign ad from his 2010 Senate
race you watch that spot at him looking
the camera talking about his message and
they said that's going to be his exact
message running running for president in
other words this is this message is how
we tried that speech he gave he's
delivered versions for that speech a
thousand times we've all seen it over
and over and over this is who he is it
is it is authentic he believes it and
he's been talking about it now when he
took on charlie Crist and everyone tried
to persuade him not to including the
Republican establishment tried to get
him to run for attorney general in
Florida and he's and he's articulating
the same message now it's almost like
it's the only message he knows and
coincidentally it works for him I think
in the primary as much as it doesn't in
general